wow
quelle diva
[Musique]
essayer beaucoup trop de robes beaucoup
trop de tenues euh
je ne peux pas dire que j'aime ce processus je ne suis pas
votre fille girly typique
[Musique]
en fait je suis allé à l'école maternelle à
Londres et c'est en quelque sorte  quand je suis tombé
amoureux du jeu d'acteur, j'avais l'habitude de monter des
productions
pour mes parents
[Musique]
avec la vidéo, je veux dire, cela a provoqué une
tempête de controverses,
vous savez, une fois qu'il est sorti, en
regardant en arrière, avez-vous des regrets de
ne pas avoir  tout, euh, vous savez que je n'avais pas
signé à l'origine pour faire la vidéo, je
n'en étais pas
convaincu, mais quand j'ai rencontré la
réalisatrice diane martell,
j'ai été vraiment impressionnée par elle et j'ai
aimé ses idées pour cela,
donc vous ne le regretterez pas  tout ça m'a
amené là où je suis
J'ai d'abord auditionné
dans une pièce pleine d'autres filles,
mais je pense que
David a vraiment aimé l'idée que
mon personnage ou même juste ma
carrière de mannequin puisse être source de division
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
Je suis une jeune femme et juste pour en faire une
chose claire
je suis ici parce que je soutiens bernie
sanders
je veux que ma première femme présidente soit
plus qu'un symbole
je veux qu'elle ait une politique qui peut
[Music]
révolutionner
donc
[Music]
démarre une entreprise en tant que femme et  une
femme qui a été considérée comme rien
de plus qu'un sex-symbol
et un mannequin peut être difficile et
très écrasante
[Musique]
pour la santé et la sécurité de la population en général
pour ceux qui sont
incarcérés et ceux qui travaillent dans
les prisons,
il est crucial que  le gouverneur cuomo
réduit maintenant la population carcérale
[Musique]
est-ce le spectacle secret de victoria